La Volta al Montapeu, day 249.
I'm back on the train to go from Jiva to the legendary and anticipated Samarkand.
Today it's not three hours, but six hours of train, all desert, all brutal desert.
In a while, I don't think we'll get to Bukhara, and I have to go to Samarkand, which is at the end of the country,
almost touching the border with Tajikistan.
Well, I think it's good to have left the most famous part and everyone says that it's the most beautiful at the end.
I'll be there at 2 p.m., I left at 7.45, there's still a lot of time left.
The taxi ride, as it was so early, there was not much demand, and the prices of Yandex, which is like Uber or Cabify, go down.
And when I got in the taxi, the guy saw what it cost and said,
Oh, Yandex!
Very little money.
Very big money, gas.
Poor thing, he didn't feel sorry.
And he told me, in fact, do you mind if another person gets on the way to the station?
I said, no, no, calm down, calm down.
And a person got on the front seat.
And then I had to go to the biggest tip that the app left me, which was 7,000.
And the guy, oh, thank you very much, thank you very much.
It was 50 cents.
I felt like a millionaire there, but it's nothing.
It's not that we are paying.
.
Good afternoon from Samarkand,
the legendary city of Samarkand, it's 5.14pm and right now I'm not in the historic centre
because I've decided that the first thing I'll see will be a mosque and a cemetery
that are here in the outskirts, between commas, a city much bigger than Bokhara
and much less hot, Bokhara was at 40ºC and here the thermometer marks a maximum of 32ºC
today, it's hot, it's hot, but well, let's see.
It's quite bearable.
Here behind me we have the mosque of Akhrat Ritz or something like that.
Today, as you can see, I'm wearing long pants because some places like this mosque
ask for a dress code to enter and well, in order not to have to put on the skirt that sometimes they give you
at the entrance of the mosque, well, I'm wearing long pants and that's it.
They are quite cool, not...
They don't warm up, they don't warm up too much.
According to what I'm explaining here, it seems that this mosque is where the remains of the first president of the Republic of Uzbekistan lie.
Let's see what it's called, I'll review it.
Islom Karimov, I don't have the plaer.
But well, I'm sure he loved his people a lot.
I would like to tell you a semi-important thing.
This comment I just made is the first and last one I make about the current and upcoming policy of the next countries I will go to.
I won't say the name, I don't need to, I don't need the algorithm to see it, I won't say absolutely anything about the next countries,
for reasons of my well-being and the well-being of my trip.
You won't hear me say too many comments about the recent, future, past history of the next three countries that are coming, okay?
You will understand me.
You don't have to look at the comments either.
Do me a favor.
What is the population of Samarkand?
Samarkand has a population of about 600,000 people, Bukhara almost 300,000 and Hiva only 115,000.
Bukhara would be a terrace, a sabadell, a badalona, and Samarkand would be the second city in Catalonia, if you are in Catalonia.
It is noticeable.
It is noticeable that...
Well...
It is noticeable that Samarkand is not so compact, I think.
Its buildings are a bit more scattered, there is more transept and all.
I think it is noticeable that Samarkand is a better place for traveling.
It is noticeable that...
Yes, the city of Bukhara is very nice, very modern, very colorful, and it has very good taste, I think, in the decoration in this country.
It has very good taste, I think, in the decoration in this country.
Now I'm going to the mausoleum that we have here at the back and I'm going to this cemetery.
The last time I recorded a Muslim cemetery, if you remember, they threw me out there in Istanbul.
So it's time to enter the necropolis of Samarkand.
From the entrance to this museum, we could say that this monument is more expensive, 80,000 sums, which is about 6 euros long.
But yes, I saw that I put, I didn't take a picture, but I put, if you go to do a shoot, 6,000 sums.
Well, just in case, I won't find the tripod and I'll record a bit of strangers and that's it.
Well, it's called the Necropolis of the Living King. Why?
Well, because in the seventh century,
the cousin of the prophet Muhammad came here to spread Islam.
And well, one day while he was praying, some infidels beheaded him.
And the legend says that he himself took his own head, went to a priest who was here,
and since then he lives here, down here.
Since then, it has become an important pilgrimage center in the Islamic world.
And it's brutal.
It's brutal.
Not only on the outside, I would say that I'm already used to these blue arches,
these turquoise, blue arches, but on the inside, these mausoleums are incredible.
They are incredible.
Well, I don't know if anyone can ever get used to this.
Obviously, it's not like the first impression in Bukhara, which was like, wow, you know?
But anyway, it's great.
And these turquoise domes,
with this oval shape, I don't know how to call it.
Very beautiful.
Wow, this is very big.
Look here, it's even more blue.
Incredible.
Well, today I want to explain something interesting, which is what the Silk Road is.
Because it's something that is talked about a lot, but what is it?
Well, I have a little more time to visit this, and then I'll explain it to you in the center of the city.
There is a mosque in the center of the city.
The mosque of Bibi Chonim.
Awesome.
Huge.
One of the largest mosques in the Islamic world, when it was built.
The largest in the central part, 15th century.
It's huge, it's brutal, huh?
Of course, it didn't sound too loud, it didn't draw so much attention, but well...
Let's go inside.
I see a tree already inside, to start.
Not a free entrance, 5 euros to enter.
Here, the citizens of Uzbekistan have a very large discount on all the attractions.
We are crazy about Catalonia and in most places there is no discount at all.
For the Sagrada Familia you have to pay the full price, for Casa Batlló too.
You are stupid.
This entrance is not worth it because the main building cannot be entered.
It is this, a 40-meter high dome.
This brought engineering to the limit of the time.
So much so that a few years later, the maons began to fall on the infidels who were praying.
I guess they had to fix it or close it or something.
Right now you can't enter.
Well, this patio is very nice.
It was founded by Tamerla, who is the one I explained to you the other day in the video of Bokhara,
which was kind of the capital of this kingdom.
In this corridor we can see the city of less than 100 million people living there at the same time.
It's said to be one of the most important ancient times.
Official territories where the new city of Bokhara was founded.
The city of Bokhara is one of the most beautiful in the world.
To be honest, I do not know if I will go there again.
I have the feeling that I will not stay there for a long time,
but I will definitely come.
I think I will not go there any more.
I mean, this is one of the most incredible places I have ever been in.
The city of Bokhara is the center square of the city of Bokhara.
The city of Bokhara is one of the most incredible places I have ever been in.
of Samarkanda, and behind me there are only the people who have paid the entrance and are in the hall at this time,
and now behind me there are people like me who don't have an entrance and are sitting here waiting for the mapping and show to start at 9, 9.30, I don't know.
Here every night they do a show, I have only seen it for social networks, I don't know if it will only be of lights, of music,
but it promises a lot, and well, without the show this place is incredible, it is not necessary, it is brutal, tomorrow we will come,
at the end of the route to the Seus I will explain tomorrow, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know, it is the three masks, I don't know what they are,
one facing the other, wow, wonderful, before the lights are more lit, now they have gone out a little, I guess preparing for the show,
then we will do one thing, I leave you with some images of the show,
I will leave you with some images of the show, I will leave you with some images of the show, I will leave you with some images of the show,
that is the summary of the mapping and tomorrow we will continue, good evening.
Thank you.
And it's the last day that I'll be doing tourism for Uzbekistan before I start walking. Tomorrow, I'll go back to Monapeu, to the videos of walking.
This seems like a good place to explain to you the Silk Road. There's not too many people, it's not too windy.
Well, let's see, the Silk Road. The name explains quite well what it is. A route, therefore, a path or a series of paths to transport silk from China to Europe.
Well, it's not entirely incorrect, but it needs to be emphasized. Let's see, this started in the 2nd century BC, when a Chinese emperor needed help to fight another army.
Then he sent an emissary to Central Asia to look for allies who wanted to help him in this company.
He didn't have much success in recruiting any army, but this emissary provided very interesting information.
He told them about the area, Central Asia, and the Chinese said that they had a special interest in trading in this area because it was quite interesting.
What did the Chinese have to offer? Silk. The silk, the Chinese had, like the secret of Coca-Cola, they were the only ones who knew how to make it.
They knew how to make it, and it was a very valuable product, extremely valuable, especially in rich societies in Europe.
And so it began to be created in these established routes.
This went on for 1500 years.
Let's see, some concepts that should be explained besides the silk route concept.
Not only was silk transported. From China, for example, paper, porcelain, tea, and from Europe, some songs were also transported from China, like silver, wine, leather.
Like silver, wine, leather.
And another interesting concept is that in other countries this was not the story.
The interesting thing is that not only the Silk Road came out of China, there were other routes that came out, for example, from India.
And from India they brought cotton, spices, precious stones.
From Persia, metals, catifes were exported.
And from Central Asia, horses, for example.
Another interesting thing to know is that at that time the Silk Road was not called.
Like many of these things, such as famous phrases and names with a lot of marketing,
all this appeared later.
Specifically, it is a term that was popularized by a German geographer in 1887.
That is, many centuries later, two or three centuries later, that this whole Silk Road issue would end.
This is a recent name.
And what else? Well, another concept, perhaps wrong,
was the fact that
you can think that the Chinese merchant came out of China with silk
and arrived in Europe after an epic journey through half the world
with his large caravan carrying a thousand things, right?
It was not like that. It was not like that, obviously.
The same product could have changed up to ten times before it arrived in Europe.
Well, the Chinese brought it here, to Samarkand,
and someone came to buy it and brought it maybe to Persia, the product in question.
And then the Persian came to the Turks, the Greeks, even to Paris, to say something, right?
And every time there was this exchange of hands, the price went up and there was a recharge here.
Then, of course, these cities on the Silk Road, such as Samarkand, Bukhara, Khiva and so on,
are cities where they not only brought the wealth of the caravans that stopped here to spend the night and to stock up, no.
Here they made exchanges.
Here, in the markets, they bought and came all these things of silk, silver, gold, paper, porcelain, and so on.
And, of course, that's why these games were so rich.
What was the moment of maximum splendor of the Silk Road?
Well, the Mongol Empire.
As you can see, the Mongol Empire was such a great empire,
because, well, if you know a bit of the history of the Mongol Empire, they conquered everything,
and it was a monstrous empire.
Then, of course, it was such a great empire that there were no wars within the empire,
and, well, there was more freedom when it came to changing kings, right?
And there weren't so many fights between friends, right?
And they could go crossing borders, so to speak, more calmly, because they didn't have them.
But the most interesting thing, and the legacy of the Silk Road to this day,
is not the exchange of silver, silk, all this.
In the end, today, what matters to us, right?
What they changed then.
The interesting thing is that, in the end, what matters to us, right?
The interesting thing is that there was also an exchange of knowledge.
Yes.
From China, it was exported through this Silk Road to Europe and other places in the world, the imprint.
The dust, also, very important.
Well, the imprint is not clear, but the paper surely arrived in Europe with this medium.
And, on the other hand, Buddhism also arrived in China through the Silk Road, right?
Yes.
These routes, as I say, were established and there were hotels in between so that the merchants could rest.
Do you know how many of these hotels there were, which were called caravanserais?
Well, every 30-40 kilometers, which is the perfect distance that I would go every day to rest in a hotel if I wanted to do this on foot, right?
Okay, and finally, when did the Silk Road end?
Well, look, it ended because of the Portuguese.
Yes, because in the 16th century, the Portuguese were the best sailors and they managed to connect Lisbon, Europe, and India by sea,
sailing South Africa to... How do you say the head of South Africa?
I don't know.
The head of Bonasperance?
No, I think this is the one from Chile.
Well, it doesn't matter.
So, they sailed and arrived in India by ship.
Sure.
And the fact of sailing by ship, well, it had the problem of pirates, but it had many advantages, which is that the whole issue of wars, the whole issue of voyages, you saved them.
You went by sea and that's it.
Then, well, this favoritism of maritime routes instead of land routes ended up destroying and reaching the decline in the 15th and 16th centuries of the Silk Road.
I have arrived at my hotel.
After lunch, I went to a plof.
I went to a ploferia, it's not called that, but it's a place where they only serve plof.
In the morning, they cook this giant pot and when it's over, it's over.
And I think it's pretty good and it's cheap, 6,000 soms, which is four euros and a half, with a bit of food and everything.
Well, today, well, nothing, I'll be here now this afternoon, organizing the material for tomorrow, because tomorrow I'll walk again.
I walk from here, from this guesthouse, and I'm a little nervous, I have to say, a little nervous about what has to come.
Not tomorrow, but the next month, especially the next month.
I don't know very well what can happen to me, but well, this is an adventure, right?
And well, I'll also be, I'll start looking at the Pakistan visa today, which I think is quite laborious to present the papers and such.
I'll start looking at the Pakistan visa today, which I think is quite laborious to present the papers and such.
will be there, at the end of Samarkand.
Well, you,
this, nervous, all the
logistics and all mixed up, I'll explain
tomorrow. For those of you who want to come to Uzbekistan,
I think more than a
week can be
too much, that is, a week
is fine, I've been here for a week.
There are more places to see, there are some fortresses,
from here you can make the
excursion to the seven yaks of Tajikistan, which is
an excursion that they take you, they visit
the seven yaks and then they return to you.
I will not recommend going there,
I will not do it, but well, if you want to
spend ten days, you can probably do it,
also some excursion through the desert, but not much more.
Then I think it's fine to come here, if
later you go to Kyrgyzstan or Kazakhstan
and you make a full pack of 20, 20 and a half days,
then yes, I recommend it,
very much.
Tomorrow begins the great adventure of the Central Press.
Good afternoon and good night.